Okay, let's get going here.
Thank you for being here.
There's
a handful of you here grateful for
that
No, this is this is critically important this night as
a whole is really critically important for what
we're doing. So, let me just make again a
reminder that if you're unaware, there are other seminars going
on at the same time right now.
various ages and stages of life and parenting
And so let me just walk through those if you want to jump out. I'm
not gonna be offended clearly by you getting up and going
if you want to to these here's the other four
that are going on right now that you could
jump into we have one centered on Foster and
adoption. And so if you're interested in that or have done that there's one
of those and it's in w 100 I believe. Is that side down
right behind the wall over there.
K through fifth grade if you land in
that and want to kind of talk through that that's in the activity center.
Down there by the cafe that's there birth through
Pre-K. If you're kind of focused on
that as parents that's w-204, which is go out
here go up the stairs. It's right behind the wall upstairs right there.
And then a student like teen parents
would be in w202 which
is upstairs right there as well. So foster adoption K
through fifth birth to pre-k student
all that. You can find your way if that's
where you would rather fit. Feel free to get up and go people out
there in the lobby could also point you directional if you
need that but those are more specific if you want to stand here. That's fine.
I'm gonna talk through some things a little more generically
generally, but you can you can
stay here of course or go.
But here's what we're going to do in here tonight. So as
we talk about parent the importance
of parenting even grandparenting a
little bit Guardians, if you're guardians of
children or teens this is going
to apply.
Because what we believe here are thesis I
guess you'd say as as a church. Our
desire is that parents are
the primary spiritual influencers in
our own kids lives.
That no other influence comes remotely close.
To that influence in a life in these these
children. No one comes close to matching that
and so what we don't want to do as a church is take
that responsibility away from you.
We don't want to try to replace that.
And so what we're trying to shift to is more of
a family equipping model where we are equipping families
equipping parents.
To to be Primary in their own kids lives and we
as a church come alongside that where we don't take the place
of we come alongside those who are
parenting. And so that's what this parenting equipping night
is for. That's why we started this we're going to
do a number of things regularly like this throughout the year.
Resourcing encouraging training all of
that to try to really come alongside parents and and
help them. And so one of the things we've done
that's a really simple way for you as parents at the
bottom of the sermon notes every week. So whether
you do it on the on the app, or you print them out at home
or you have there's at each entrance, there's
stacks of them that you can grab on the way in for Sundays
at the bottom of those and we post them on social media
as well at the bottom is what we call TalkBack questions.
Really simple three simple questions. They're nothing
profound, right? You're just going to have a
starter question or two or three
for you as a family. So imagine at
lunch. You've all just heard the same
message and you go home and you talk about it over
lunch or that evening or next day or whatever.
That's one of those ways to just take a baby step towards
family equipping so take advantage
of those things. Those are simple ways. It doesn't take much to ask a
question and see where it goes and God does a lot with that. But
again that all goes back to that really the desire
we have is to equip parents and come alongside
parents towards that end.
as we as a church support that
and so what I want to do tonight
Really just laying out groundwork foundational elements
many of you are in very different stages of
parenting. It's not this is the hard hard
one because we're all a mishmash of
stages where we're at. But this will
apply a thank you have if you
have kids at home, of course, this will apply if you have kids that
are now out of the house and kind of how do you parent from afar
then it will be for you who are grandparents
and you're influencing your grandkids in new ways and and then
just generically spiritual parenting and
grandparenting in the church.
Right. This is something that we have as a responsibility together first
as parents of children, but then
in the church context where we're coming
around parents and discipling their kids
alongside them. So this is going to
be something that I hope will cross over all those boundaries.
And we're going to talk through some important pieces of that but then I think the
best way for these type of things to work is for just Q&A.
Right. So we're going to try to leave some time at the end for some good
amount of Q&A to make it relevant. Like I might
cover what I think is important, but what do
you think's important? What do you want to know about and I might not have the best
answer. We've got Collective wisdom in the room that can help us answer
that but I want to leave time for that. Make sure
it works. So begin to think a questions now or along
the way and we'll try to see what God's word says
about that.
But what we're going to do to get there is we're going to start by
going to God's word Ephesians 6:4 so pull out your copy of
God's word and turn there with me.
Ephesians 6:4 there's a lot of ways we could go with this
a lot of places we could land in Scripture.
But I'm gonna read all of verse 4.
And then we're going to come back through it piece by piece.
Ephesians 6:4
Says fathers do not provoke your children to
anger.
But bring them up in the discipline and instruction of the
Lord.
Fathers do not provoke your children to anger but bring them up in the discipline and
instruction of the Lord Ephesians 6:4.
So remember the way that Ephesians is structured.
Where the first three chapters are Paul's summary
of The Gospel.
The implications of that for our Salvation And how that fleshes out
in our lives. So rich first three
chapters would be worth your year of study.
But then the last three chapters of Ephesians are its outflow
the gospels outflow in life, like
practical a lot of day-to-day things
in the church in relationships in prayer
in work, all of that comes out
of this idea of the gospel outflow.
And so then not only does he talked about all that stuff.
He talks about marriage. He talks about parenting.
Applying the gospel into those elements.
That's what this section is.
Because of what God has done for us.
Parents do this right? Like this is a response to
the gospel. Just like all the rest of it is.
So let's look at it. Let's dig into a first he says fathers
and that's a legitimate translation of
the Greek text. It's pateir fathers.
Now as he says this does this exempt
mothers from this role? Well, no, of course
obviously mothers have a critical role in parenting.
In instructing and disciplining children as well.
But what he's doing here is he's highlighting this expectation.
That's throughout scripture.
That fathers have the leading responsibility in
the home.
Not the only but the leading responsibility in the home to
carry this burden in the first and foremost
kind of way to Shepherd to Pastor
them as his children.
So let that be first and primary right?
Let's let's make sure that can be as ideal
as it can but I also realize that's not everybody's situation.
We have a lot of things that are different than
that ideal certainly, but we want to
push towards that and and disciple people towards that
yes, but there's a whole lot of unique situations around.
And so tonight just for the context of this we're going to think of the
word parents here who says fathers. Yes. We
know what that means. But that this is for all of us.
He says parents possibly even grandparents or
Guardians if that's the situation that you're in and that's how
you can have influence on these kids that God's entrusted to
us. Then let that be who you are reading this as right.
so parents
grandparents Guardians Ephesians 6:4 then
says God's word says do not provoke your
children to anger.
Some translations say Do not exasperate your
children.
We don't talk really like that anymore. We don't use that word very
often.
Basically, all that means is do not come alongside your
children and make them angry.
That word for provoking to anger is this you
come alongside them and anger them?
Not just from afar. You're actually with them. And so
Don't provoke them to anger is what God's word says
now, here's the reality of this. We know that most children get
upset when you discipline them, right?
They don't look at you and say thank you. Like that's not what
they do. So there's an anger that just naturally comes
up.
And he even says here in six four includes the word discipline.
So he's not talking about.
Completely abdicating discipline from your
life so that you don't anchor them.
Like well, I can never correct them because that's gonna anger them. That's
not what he's saying here, right?
So what does this mean?
What kind of things is he talking about here?
We don't want to provoke them to anger. That's what he says not to do. And so what's
he talking about? We're gonna be real practical here.
Well, here's here's the the primary way. This applies first
and foremost this means
That you take your faith seriously yourself.
So that they don't see a disconnect between the way
you live out there and the way you live at home.
Because think about that.
I'm not saying you have to be academic or overly religious
or you got to be weird about your faith. I'm not saying any of
those things. You just make it your number one priority revolve
everything around else around it in public in
private at church not at church,
right? You're making it. Look this is
the same everywhere. You're making it normal because here's what
happens your kids and everybody around you
really but talking kids primarily they pick
up on that stuff.
They pick up on that. They see it.
And the reality is your discipling your kids one way or the other.
Like towards something you want or away from
that thing that that you're you're training them
in a way to put their church hat on
when they go to church, but then the rest of their life they can do whatever they
want with it.
You're in a sense discipling them towards that
as their lifestyle.
And you wonder why we have so many people leaving the church.
In droves over the last Decades of
people who grew up in the church, like where why
are they leaving? Why are they why are they saying they
don't believe in God anymore? Why is that the case well, because
a lot of it is due to this.
They saw their parents.
live one way publicly or live one way at church and
then
not at home at all.
It's not the only reason don't think it's like don't I'm not heaping
shame on you if that's what you see your kid walking away. That's not
only the reason.
But it's a big reason.
because they say
to you as a parent like it didn't matter to you.
and they just do it because they have to till they get out of the house and
they're just gonna do what you did and we play a game.
Religiously publicly, but then we do it our own way and
and the further that gets away from the source the
less that's going to happen.
And so we should not as children. They should not question whether
you really believe the stuff
or not.
There shouldn't be a disconnect between the way we are publicly the
way we are at church. They should have no question that
that's really
Really what you believe?
That means it must be the priority of your life first.
Should be number one in your heart.
Because if we have this command do not provoke your children
to anger one way that happens is when they
see the disconnect.
They see that you're different over here than you are over here. They see
that you're more kind to people in this circle because
it's public and you're just a jerk to them.
Like, you know Europe it's okay not to be
okay here. So I'm leading out in that there was a there was
a time.
Where my wife asked me this question?
I'm trying to think how long it was when I was at Weatherford. So
eight ten years ago somewhere in there.
And she asked this question. Why are you more alive
at church than you are at home?
like talk about that just
shot to the gut
that that I get in this world and I'm alive and
I'm interacting with people all the time and I'm just destroyful over
but you know over the top right and and then
I get home and I'm just like
phone, you know, whatever.
She noticed which means my boys were not old enough yet to really see
all that thankfully, but she could see that the trend was
negative towards that and it called me out.
So are you the same?
home
At work as you are around the people
that you're supposed to put the front on with right.
Let's not make it a different thing. Let's make it the same kids pick up on
that that increases their provocation towards anger because
they just resent.
What they see.
So you take your faith. Seriously number one, that's number one
for you.
Second here's another practical way to avoid provoking them to
anger.
Don't be overbearing.
Don't be overbearing with your kids or grandkids or
whoever.
Now it's one thing as he says to bring them up in
the discipline instruction of the Lord. We'll get to that in a little bit.
It's another thing to come down hard on everything they
do.
If you if you if you expect perfection.
Out of a child or a teenager they will fail you.
every time
and they'll feel that.
when you nitpick every little thing that they do
Like and hear me again as a type A personality. This
is really hard for me to let go of
and he's going to do it a little differently than I am.
And I'm it's hard for me not to try to control that.
And nitpick it and and just kind of come down on every little
thing.
I have to let that go but if I expect Perfection out
of a nine-year-old, it's like
I'm not even perfect. I can't expect
Perfection of myself. So let alone somebody who has no
idea how the world Works yet.
But the more you do this the more you come down on everything
the more you're overbearing the more they
resent everything about
that.
It provokes anger, they'll shut down and
they'll be angry about most everything.
I said there's a lot of places we could go for this tonight. It's what Colossians
3:21 says.
It's almost the exact similarity to Ephesians 6:4.
But here in Colossians, it adds a result.
It says do not provoke your children.
Lest they become discouraged.
So it's not just about like provoking them to
anger.
He says you're going to provoke them to anger and they're going to get discouraged.
They will become discouraged because of these
things so our job should be
to encourage not to discourage.
To add courage not take away courage from our
children.
And if we're overbearing it will discourage because
they can never win. They can never speak successful. They
can never measure up.
And it's always you're always failing and that's just
discouraging to everybody.
Now here's a third way to avoid provoking them
to anger.
I'm going to show you a video to get us there, but I want to set
it up first before we show it.
This is going to be.
Kind of a psychologist observing a
psychologist experiment.
So he's watching this experiment happen and he's commenting on
it from an outsider's perspective.
but the whole experiment originally was
was watching and testing how children
react to facial expressions and
engagement with a parent.
I remember the first time I saw this it just blew me away to watch
this and you'll see it in a moment. It's profound but but the
person you see Talking there's actually captions on
it. But the person you see Talking is Dr. David
pooter I think is how you
say his name, but
He's a psychologist in California. I would
not recommend listening to him. Like
don't go find his body. Like that's not what we're doing with this. This is
not an endorsement of him, but it is
really an amazing Glimpse from
his perspective psychologically to know what's happening
in this experiment and we'll take what he says with
a grain of salt. There's still some stuff, of course in this that we want
to be careful with.
But what I want you to observe in this is
is how the child responds.
And you'll see what I mean when we get to it, but we're gonna
watch the video. I'll come back explain how it applies what we're talking about here
tonight, but just watch the child. You'll see what I mean.
Today I'm going to go through one of my favorite videos a
video that literally changed my life. When I saw this the first
time I watched it probably 10 times in a row because there
was so much going on psychologically and so
much that just my eyes opened about how sophisticated
Young children one year olds are at
regaining connection with their mother. And so I'm just going
to start it right here. And in the very beginning we can see how
the mother and the infant are playing wonderfully together. So the
the mothers moving her hands the babies moving
her hands the baby looks over at something the
baby looks at the mother the eyebrows go
up the baby. The mother's eyebrows go up the baby points mother looks
so they're interacting. This is what play looks like.
This is what a well-connected child with her mother looks like Mother's tickling
the child the child giggles and laughs the
child. It looks at
the mother looks away a little bit mother. Okay. Not
now, I'm gonna pause it right here. So in the experiment what
happens is they ask the mother to have a
still face hence still face experiment. And so they ask
her to look at the child but to completely go
flat, okay.
Here we go. The mother looks flat at the child
the baby kind of like
doesn't quite know what to do. Does this little feigning.
Look puts the puts his arm up because usually
that engages play, okay.
Next the baby points because that usually engages
play.
But the mother has his still face yet. Okay. Now the baby
tries to reach to mother to reengage her
now right here. I'm pausing it. You can see a Grimace
on an expression of anger on this
infant's face and the
infant is trying to reconnect but it's not
able to reconnect
Okay, and so the the infant goes from like a playful way
of re-engaging connection to more of an angry.
Fight and flight way of reengaging connection, okay.
So the infant is making some loud screeching noises. The infant is
clapping.
Making loud noises now watch this right here the
infant.
bites himself
I'm positive again. This is the beginning
of self-harm.
This infant is harming himself as a way of distress because
he is distressed.
Because he's distressed due to a lack
of connection a lack of mirroring a lack
of play a lack of being able to re-engage his mother. Okay, let's
continue.
So now the infant reaches to his mother doesn't work.
So the infant starts to look away.
So the infant now is body is contorting.
He's lost body posture.
and it's really interesting because the baby is going
from a kind of a fight and flight place to a shutdown
okay to more of a dissociative place to a
place of
having its body be
discombobulated or disoriented so it starts by
looking away avoidance, right and then just kind of
like
a decelibate posturing
the child is very strict distressed. Now. I want you to watch I'm playing this
now.
The mother re-engage the child. So this is a healthily.
Attached mom healthy secure attachment and look the
baby goes back to marrying the baby goes back to play immediately.
The baby puts its arms up mother puts his
arms up baby with some down mother put their arms down. They go
back to marrying.
So this video teaches us a couple really really important
things not only about how to interact
with our children.
But also how to play Not only
with children but also with our spouses with our
loved ones and with our patients, right? So a lot
of play is marrying. It's looking
at each other's emotions. It's looking
at each other's desires, right the baby points mother
looks
your spouse points at something interesting. You look. Oh,
yeah, that's interesting.
Often though. What happens is we get
in our own head, right? So getting in our own
head keeps us from being able to play, you know, getting into our own ego as
the cloak wheel term would describe ego. You know, when you're
thinking only of yourself, it's really hard to think of
your spouse. It's really hard to think of your patient.
so
Coming back to what are the body languages? What
are the micro Expressions? What is this person Desiring
and then getting excited or
enthusiastic or plain with
them? Right? It's kind of like entering into
that moment. So as you looked at that video and rewatch this
a couple times think about one, what would a depressed
mother look like what we know they would be less emotionally engaged
compared to a normal mother. What would
an alcoholic or a drug abusing mother or father look
like with their child. We know once again, there are
less engaged.
And imagine, you know a parent
always on their phone. Okay. I know when I go
on my phone around my kids they may get more agitated early
on maybe they're getting into that more fight and flight
stage and whereas if I'm playing, you know, and we're
sitting down doing some Legos and I'm mirroring them. It's like all fun. It's
like they're totally engaged in that playful state.
okay, so the trick with both our kids our spouses our
patients is
To remain in this playful State. Okay, and
to enter into someone else's exuberance.
And if you notice that at one point the child needed some
space and the mother gave him some space.
So we want to both marry each other.
and to connect
and that's what this video taught me like no other
video has
today
is that not profound to watch happen
instantly, right?
But there's so many applications here.
Is called the still face experiment. You can go find even lengthier videos
on that online. You can go find that as you need
to.
But here's what I believe it. It shows us for our purposes
here tonight.
One of the ways as we look at Ephesians 6:4
that we can provoke our children to anger or we can
exasperate our children. One of the ways is
by disengaging from their lives.
And so this applies not just for those of us with little kids
this applies for you with your grandkids this
applies for you with your adult kids. It applies for
you with your spouse you with friends you with other
family like this is this is so much bigger than
just parenting right now, right?
because that applies in every
relationship we have
and so for our kids, for example, we can disconnect ourselves
from them emotionally.
Whether the babies or whether they're teenagers and you
see their natural response to that.
We know it's true. Like inherently when we start to think about it like
that. Yeah, of course, we see that happen, and then they disconnect from
us and they just completely pull away
and they don't want to have anything and listen if they
don't want to talk to you.
That's a closed door to so many other things.
If they have disengaged because you disengage with them. That's
a problem for the future.
That they might listen, but they won't hear you.
They might have to do what they have to do. But as
soon as they're having the ability to get out of the house, they're
out and they're never coming back.
And so instead what do we do?
If we don't want to exasperate or
provoke them to anger.
We don't want to disengage from their life. What do we do instead? We
must Delight in our children in
our teens.
You heard the doctors say that right to?
To enjoy them to get involved in
their exuberance and be a part of
their lives mirror play all of those things. I would
say it like this. He said this to be curious.
about their interests
if you have multiple kids, you know, every one of them is different.
Your grandkids you look at every one of them is different.
And what worked with this one doesn't work with this one and what they're excited
about is not what they're excited about. So you have to be curious and
ask about who they are and what
God's made them to enjoy and that inclines their
heart towards you and towards the Lord.
in that desire
So we have to engage their lives.
We see the results of what happens when we don't even from a
baby.
Just think about your teenagers.
So what we have to do then we've got to meet their emotional needs.
So we provide for our kids physically.
hopefully spiritually
just as much as we do that we have to provide for them emotionally.
I've got a simple chart here that I want to show you and I talk through
that's along these same lines. I don't know if we'll be able to
see every piece you can see some of it.
But this deals with relational needs.
And it kind of goes with the video. We just saw and how you would
think about that. There are relational needs that every
person has especially our kids and our grandkids those
around us.
So you've got two tracks here. There's a potential of
needs met. That's the top. That's the green that if
you're going to meet those needs, here's the track. We'll talk about a second in
the bottom. The red is the pain of needs missed.
We'll talk about what happens there. But think about
that as a relational need with you and a
kid you and a teenager.
Let's say they meet you meet that need and
you're engaged with them and you're involved that need is
met.
That leads that child to think truthful things
to think right things about what's happening right now and
and what you would tell them that they're thinking
in a right sense of the word. They also have been positive feelings as
a result of that.
That they they get this from you and their needs met and they're thinking
rightly and then they have positive feelings because of that that leads
to productive behaviors.
It doesn't guarantee that they're going to obey everything you say because they're kids
they're not perfect, but it leads a lot more to productive
behaviors and then positive outcomes on the
other end, right?
That's if the needs are met.
But what about the pain of needs that are missed? It's
just the flip side of that that need is unmet.
You've disengaged you're on your phone all the time
that that engagement the care the the
time with them the Curiosity about
them that has not been met and that kid feels alone that
kid feels like they have nothing.
To meet their need relationally that need is unmet leads
to faulty thinking.
They might I don't think they love me. There's nobody
loves me.
Nobody cares about me.
I'm worthless.
Faulty thinking leads to painful feelings.
That they then feel inside that they have because
of that faulty thinking and it
leads to an emotional state. That's
painful
Which leads to unproductive behaviors?
And negative outcomes.
Right. What was amazing? He mentioned this. He stopped the video when the child bit
itself because it didn't know what to do with this
emotional disengagement.
It went through that really fast. The need was not met it began
to think.
Nothing, really. I don't know what to do with this. So painful feelings led
to unproductive behaviors. Like I'm scared. I'm
despite my hand.
And we just exponentially.
Scope that out for a teenager.
So this is a way for us to think okay emotional needs
matter.
Engagement with a child matters clearly
not meeting relational emotional needs sets our children
up to be angry and to be separated from us.
Are teenagers it sets them up?
to be angry to be exasperated as scripture says not
to be
And here's what happens. We we track this negative behavior
down here the negative outcomes the unproductive
behaviors. What often happens?
Whenever we see a child or a teen show one
of those unproductive behaviors.
We try to swoop in at that moment and correct it.
We truth the deed you would say.
They did something and we throw a bunch of Truth on top of it to try
to fix it.
You know, you're not supposed to do that.
Haven't I told you not to do that before, you know, that's gonna be wrong. You
know, that's gonna be terrible for you. Like why would you do that that
we truth the deed even throwing Jesus on
top of that sometimes right? We truth the deed we
tell them how to fix it instead. Maybe what we
need to do is go back and meet the need.
That led down that negative track.
That they weren't getting something emotionally relationally from
you. So they ran down this faulty thinking
this feelings and they added the behavior
on top of it.
When maybe we should have gone back and met a need to begin with.
Meet the need don't just truth the deed.
so
instead of provoking them to anger as
scripture just said not to do.
Were commanded here in Ephesians 6:4. Let's
continue the verse.
Bring them up in the discipline and instruction of the
Lord.
Bring them up in the discipline and instruction of
the Lord.
And here's what's interesting that word for bring them up in Ephesians.
6:4 is the same word that is used to
nourish in a physical way.
So you're like I said before feeding them.
You're making sure their needs are met that they're safe. They're
protected you have that you're also.
Nourishing them in the discipline and instruction of
the Lord spiritually you're called to
nourish them. That's our primary responsibility parents.
Hours not the churches. It's ours as
parents to nourish them spiritually the leading responsibility
in our homes as parents is to Pastor
them to lead them toward Jesus again. Remember that means
you better be leading yourself and following
Jesus hard yourself first so
you can help them.
But if we are to bring them up nourish
them spiritually that means we must
be teaching them the Bible teaching them
the gospel teaching them about God at home.
We can't Outsource this to the church.
This this should be a place your home
should be the place that they come to ask gospel questions first.
That should be the culture of your home as grandparents as parents
that you feel. This is the place they're going to come first
to ask the Bible questions to ask the
Jesus questions. Not may not I can't wait
till Wednesday get to see Miss Kelly and I'm gonna ask her about that.
She should come to you Mom.
My dad she should come to you first to
ask these questions because that's what the culture is
you've created.
Now you might not know the answer, right?
Dad What's the Trinity like okay, you might have to get some help on
that one. I have to get help on that one. So it's okay.
But they should want to ask you because that's the
relationship they see first.
Praying over them.
It should be going to battle when
you look at the rest of Ephesians 6. There's all about spiritual warfare prayer.
You should be going to war for your kids and
your grandkids.
Praying over them praying apart from them that they hear
you pray for them directly face to face as they go
to bed as the eat food. Like you're you're praying over
them that they know this is what we do. It's not just the
guy on the stage on Sunday prays like no dad prays
all the time for me.
Both I know it because he doesn't in front of me and he's
doing it behind the scenes. Mom is writing scripture down praying. Like
that's one thing my wife did.
When we first had our first son she got a
Bible and we did this together, of course, but she does it
way better than I do.
She
nearly daily will read through that Bible
wherever she's reading goes into that Bible and prays
that scripture for the the boy. We put
his name on the front of it.
And she'll pray that and write the date and maybe a word
or two of encouragement or something that she prayed for him and go
through all three of them now, but we just have
done it now with Noah for 13 and a half years.
We've done it for Luke 11 and a half years. We've
done it for Levi for nine years and they will get that Bible.
At some point, we're not sure when 16 maybe 18
at some point. They will get that Bible and
it is just filled.
with Mom praying for them
and what that word is I've done it a little bit too. It's harder for
me to get into that and do it. That's just what she's decided to
do and yet it's got all of that in
there.
Because she's going to war for my kids for our kids.
So that is part of it as well. If we
are to bring them up.
In the discipline instruction of the Lord. This should
be a part of it.
But also don't you think about this? So we
We said the word nourish is the same here. Bring them up.
We're considering these rhythms of parenting grandparenting like
kind of what we should focus on how we do this.
think about
how much effort?
We spend on goals.
education
talents
for our own kids
taking all the sports and practices and all the things.
Grandparents you're like celebrating things and going to
games and you're you're walking through that with them and
you're taking this one to proactive because mom's got to take this one. Like you're
you're helping out and and we're putting so much effort and
energy into that.
Those goals that education tools Sports all of that.
But here's a question.
What if that child gets to the age of 20?
They're very successful.
honors student in high school
All district they're in a good college.
Right there physically attractive they're talented. They're
they've got everything that Edmund would
want to produce right?
But you failed to lead them to Christ.
Like what's that worth in the end?
That's a piercing question.
Like think about this is a
a solid B- student.
Who doesn't have any sports ability in them?
But loves Jesus passionately.
Is that enough for you?
Is that enough?
Would that be a successful parenting Journey?
And you know all these other families all these other kids are doing all this big stuff and
their National Honors all that stuff. You know, that's who they
are.
But your kid is kind of the average middle the
ground whatever but they love Jesus and they're willing
to go wherever he calls them.
Is that enough?
Because there's an inherent pressure.
from all sources towards that other side
is this enough?
Really? Shouldn't that be gold number one?
Should not be the most important thing we want for them. I
don't care if you make it to college.
I don't care if you have a successful Sports career.
I care that you're gonna stand before God someday and
he's gonna look at you and say Well done good and faithful, sir.
And in my kids' lives that is priority number
one.
And that is my primary responsibility is to
do everything. I can to set them up to know
and follow Jesus. I can't guarantee that.
There's no formula to this. There's no way you
can guarantee your kid ends up that way. It's no.
Ability on your part to do that which is
why we better pray, so I better trust the Lord.
But I better set the table.
I better make it as easy and as
likely as possible for them to follow him.
That they see it in me. They know it's true that
I believe it that I'm living like it that I'm repenting when I fail that Jesus
really is who I am following the gospel
is my source and they know that this is what's
priority for our family. We're not going to miss church on
Sundays for that. We're not going to do this. We're gonna make it we're
gonna sacrifice and give like they know that's what we do.
and then if it's
it's up to them.
Then it's up to them to follow Jesus or not.
Between him and them that's what we want to.
Keep perspective here.
It's not wrong to pursue Sports not wrong
to pursue good grades. Don't hear me say that it's just we
better keep that in perspective. What is
most important in their life?
It's maybe not what everybody else says is important.
Jesus following him. That's it.
and along with that as we nourish them bring them up in our
lives his grandparents even
We better make sure that they can own their faith before
they leave the house.
As much as we can help them that they like you
think about it you hope that when they graduate high
school go to college, that's what they do or they move off and
get a job or something like you. Hope they can feed themselves you hope they can drive you.
Hope they know how to pave bills right? You you
hope that's what they know how to do you better even more.
So hope they can do this Faith thing themselves.
that's why we
We've worked hard here at the church to try to make it where nobody
feels like.
they're they have to choose between church or
youth or church or kids like we
want this to be when this
child born here grows up through 18 and they graduate and leave
and they go somewhere else to a different church because they've moved to school or
moved to a job or whatever that they know what church actually
looks like and functions like that. They've been
a part of the church.
Not just part of the youth ministry or part of the kids' Ministry.
They know what the church is like.
And they know what would like to function as an adult.
In their faith before they go that's the goal
we have.
primarily yours as parents and ours as parents, but the
church comes alongside that
just like we hope to nourish them into those other things. We hope to nourish them
into their own faith Journey that they can own it and
live it.
Because notice what Ephesians 6:4 says we bring them
up in.
the discipline and instruction of the Lord
In other words, this is a gospel Focus.
Not just discipline instruction where they
learn a lot of things. They're good citizens. They know how to handle themselves
that they are in the Lord discipline instruction
of the Lord.
Which means we teach them who God is as we go Deuteronomy
success, but also systematically teach them.
Who he is, but again, I keep coming back to this.
The problem is that recent research has shown.
The vast majority of parents do not hold a biblical
worldview.
Like not understanding legitimately.
Who God is how that works out in our
lives?
There's a legitimate.
Failure at some point somewhere throughout
history to train people how
to see the world through God's lenses.
What he says goes how he says we are to
be and so when you think about even the challenge
to pass on this to our
children, what are we passing on?
Again, we as parents must understand first
and foremost who God is and how
to how to follow him. We've got to be followers of
him first.
That's what we then pass on the things of the Lord.
Not just how to be a good American citizen how to
be a follower of Christ. They need to learn that from us.
How to understand who God is and believe in
his word what he said and how to study his word.
They've got to learn that somewhere.
And you can't Outsource that.
It has to be first and foremost in your home.
Now he does say something here about discipline.
I'm not going to get into all of that because the word here has to
do with training.
meaning
You don't just teach them what to do you teach them how to do it.
train someone
it's a long process a lifelong journey, but you walk alongside
them not to prod anger, but to
show them how to follow Jesus themselves.
Not just lecturing them about how to follow Jesus but actually
showing them how to follow Jesus walking together again.
You better know how to do that first.
And if you need some help for that come back next week Phil will
tell you how to do it right get in a d group get into micro
group. You'll have the help you need and I'm not
joking about that. I'm serious if if you don't know.
how to follow Jesus you can't teach your kids how to follow
Jesus
so get help.
get around a couple guys get around a couple women and just
say
I don't know how to do this.
and you won't get this from people like
and
somebody should have taught you before now. You're too
late.
No, what you'll get is somebody saying, okay, let's
do this. Come on.
Let me show you let me teach you. Let me walk with you and a crash
course through some things. Let me help you quickly get up to speed
and then let me walk with you encouragement not discouragement.
So that you can help train your kids.
Teach them train them instruct them.
Now there is corrective training at times right? Don't do
this do that. Yes.
They should come in anguish come not in Anger should
anguish.
We're talking about don't provoke your children to anger. You better not be angry at them
as you discipline them. It just gets it worse. It
amps it all up, right.
So discipline, yes.
does matter
But it should be an anguish over the Rebellion against God.
Not their failure to meet your
standard.
But here's what I want to do before we get to some Q&A real quick.
When I I'm writing this stuff down.
To communicate it as you're hearing these things and it is
always no matter when or what stage
you're in it is always a daunting responsibility.
I mean it's over the top really there's so much
weight that can be lumped on our shoulders in this
like oh I fail like when you get older and your kids start to get
out, I'm sure this happens even more because it happens in my age as
I've got 13 11 9.
Like the further you go in this the regrets get like
larger.
About what you failed at or what? You
didn't do. Well he just
That's not the point of this. It's not what we're trying to do. We're not
trying to lump on more shame.
what we're trying to show is that
what we're saying in this is not about your competency.
to do it
It is your responsibility as a parent as a grandparent
these roles. We've been given. Yes, it's your responsibility, but it's
not about your competency because you
are weak.
I'm weak.
I cannot do this.
But that's okay.
Because what that does.
Is it drives you to Jesus?
It drives you to Jesus when you see there's something insurmountable in
your life. It just forces you to Jesus.
It's a heavy weight. Yes.
But it's a great privilege.
That he is entrusted to you.
To have a direct influence in a disciple making
kind of way with someone who lives in your house all the time.
What a gift.
As a grandparent that God is entrusted to you. These precious little ones you
can actually give away at night and not take home, but you can like have
the influence you have on these children.
What a privilege that is.
It's overwhelming to think of how we could ever do that. But
to have a ready-made disciple making opportunity right inside your
own home or in your family.
What a great opportunity.
So the weight is great. Yes, but don't let that overwhelm instead.
Let that drive you to Jesus.
Okay. So what kind of questions do you have? We've got.
15 plus minutes here
to just dig through some things that either I didn't
cover or
More application based questions and then if
I can't answer it, I'll ask somebody else to answer it in the room who's a lot
more wise than I am.
What do you have? What are some thoughts questions you had to come up along the
way about the video about the chart. It's gonna see any of those again a
video you can find online but the chart
or something like that love to
have some dialogue about this.
Yeah.
Some Godly ways that I've influenced my children.
Yeah, so some good practices on like how to really build
this into habits and rhythms in the house. Okay.
So when we were we had little ones at home.
We built a rhythm every single night.
That we would read.
Ended up being Jesus storybook Bible, which is a great resource how it
just kind of goes through stories of the Bible and points to Jesus before that.
There's a couple other ones that are more simple even than
that big picture storybook Bible.
A couple other ones have come out now but every night.
From birth we'd read with our kids.
And just have the Bible there right before
I would do it bath time read time bedtime. Like
that's how we did it.
and our boys have
taken that ownership themselves now where they read before
they go to bed. It's not even us doing it all the time.
But that was something we started babies all
the way through and they they would jump up in the
chair all that stuff. So that was just a way
to embed. I love for reading first of all, but then
a love for Jesus.
Through his word as much as we could for a simple.
simple ways
we have never really read Through the Bible with them
like that. It was more like the story books
Bible early on now the reading the Bible themselves, but we just
want to build that into our lives.
We try to eat meals as many times as possible
together.
And that means we're eating at 4:30 some nights most
nights of the week because of practices that
night but we're trying to make that apart. We have like a highs lows
conversation at the dinner table and we apply the gospel to
some of those situations that we see. Sometimes it's just
Yeah, we had a tough day and we're grieving or
lamenting together. We had a great day and celebrating. It's not
a heavy gospel sermon conversation
every time sometimes it just fun and
sometimes it's not fun to eat together, but it's
a rhythm we tried to build and that's just family time
connection the engagement the emotional stuff.
We've tried.
I get a little bit.
Don't take this wrong. I get a little bit weirded out when people say
you have to do Family Worship like this every time
every night.
I can get there. Of course.
That's your family great. It's not us.
We just never have been able to we don't sing
together, right? That's that's just who we are.
Our boys don't really like it. So we just don't do it.
We listen to music all the time in the car. So we're
kind of got that going gospel songs.
But to say has to work this certain way every
time I don't think that's that's right
because you look at Deuteronomy six and there's there's Court
of this as you go idea.
We just constantly are asking them questions in the
car.
See something like hey, how's that point to God's glory? Just something
like that and get some to think for a second or what's
something you're struggling with and we'll talk about
a verse that goes with that.
But the family worship time for us has just never been a really solid rhythm.
It never worked but for us it's like
all of life. Is this way Deuteronomy six?
So there's other things and I'd love to hear anything else that
you guys have tried other things that have worked or
not worked anything that you would share that's been good.
habits rhythms of life to be spiritual influencers
in your kids
Yeah.
Yeah, the question is about social media.
and
what can be our role in limiting that because of its effects
and I think you can go to every study even Facebook itself meta
now, whatever they call.
has studies that show and they were kind of leaked out a couple
months ago about how Instagram
has
been proven to
to show in teenage girls and younger, especially
a much higher risk towards
self-harm and
It all stems from this comparison game. Like
they're self-image is so much lower like Studies
have proven this.
Because they're on Instagram. Like that's the only thing.
Just because they're looking at these fake pictures and how people
are posing everything. It's all a created
image and they're like, I don't compare to that.
And so you get this cycle, right? You get the negative feelings. They
haven't they don't have an emotional need met from a parent a
dad. So they're gonna find it somewhere else and that's
a dangerous place to be
so for us
I don't think there's a hard and fast rule but for us.
We're considering not even let him be on social media at all till they're
out of high school.
For sure already our oldest got a phone
beginning at seventh grade merely because after school
practice, where are you going to be? We got to meet
you. When do you when you're done those kind of things but it's one of those phones it's
it's a pinwheel pinwheel. If
you've heard of those that kind of are restricted phones
you can do this with an iPhone as well. I think.
But it is geared towards
making it a super dumb phone.
Where you can't get apps that I don't put on the
air on the phone for you and they're not even all those
social media apps at all. It's just chess or weather or
whatever every text that
comes in. That's not a number. We've already checked and
approved is sent to a folder that I get to look at before it
goes to his phone and then I can approve it or deny it.
So nobody can just text him randomly. No pictures can come
through like you just get a random, you know, you get
those spam text messages that are just right that
can't come. So we've just chosen to
make it really restrictive. But then you can release it over
time. You can let them have more freedom with
it as they get older as they earn
that trust. I think that's one of the biggest things you just give them. I
just I can't imagine having
Phone like I have now when I was in high
school.
knowing the way I was how that
is like a
poison
Right there in my pocket.
And Imagining the access. So if
you have any
if you have no acts no no restrictions on it. I
think that's unwise
I think they're God there has to be some some understanding
that they don't know how to process this stuff yet,
and you have a measure of protection.
But you can help them. That's this not saying shelter them.
This is saying help them understand how to handle it.
And a firm who they are meet the emotional needs. They're
not looking for it on social media or looking for it at school or wherever
else like you've got to find this way to have the connection.
To have the conversation about it.
But I think it is going to prove to be much more dangerous than
we realize right now.
Again studies already showing this stuff. It's going to prove in
10 30 years how
destructive this stuff really is to us.
I would encourage you go watch social dilemma.
It's on Netflix. It's a documentary the social
dilemma.
It's people who invented social media now regretting they
did it and talking about how it actually works and what
they do to manipulate you psychologically and
how it's like gamifying everything and it
just sucks you in and pulls you in and it's all that you are
the product.
You are a child is the product I said it
kind of Sunday, right like commercials advertisements during Paw
Patrol
on TV is a way to
manipulate your child's psychologically so that
they get you to buy something for them.
That's actually happening.
And I'm not sky is falling crazy. Like, you know, I'm not gonna go
live in the woods. Like that's not who I am because I'm involved in the
world, too.
But we've got to be aware. There's stuff like that going on.
And be careful with those children that God's entrusted to
us to bring them up in the discipline instruction of Lord including how
are you going to live in a world? That's just driven by
technology.
Everything around us. It's not going away.
As much as we want to go back to dumb phones. It's not going to happen.
You train, how can you train your child how to deal with
that how to navigate that how to handle it how to be wise according
to what God says about it. It's a dangerous
thing that we've got to be careful about and there's a lot more Jason kushmal
is one of our deacons here.
He is a professional about social media
and that whole thing. It's his job as a
detective basically to research
that and dig into the back side of that the really
bad side of that.
He can help you. So if you want help on that we can have you.
Sit on with him. He's got a seminar. Actually that's already been online
or been recorded we can give it to you but
How to navigate that with your kids so we've
got the help here if you need that. If you want that, please just let
us know. It's great question. I think it's important for sure.
Anything else what else?
a couple minutes left
I've got a couple comments too. If I always ask a question.
I got a couple more.
Just random items I could say.
Well, let me let me finish up with a couple things here and then I
want to pray together.
These are a couple just random comments. I had written down that
didn't know if I'd get to or not.
make sure
make sure that we as a church are supportive of those for bringing
kids into the worship Gathering.
So this is talking to all of us.
one of the things I think we're seeing in my generation in lower
is a desire to to have
our children in there from
Really early age and bring them up knowing church
not just knowing kids ministry, which
is they're not against it. Nobody's against it. It's just we want
our kids to be in the church with all generations.
And that's a challenge because they're kids and they're
distracting and they're not knowing how
to sit and sometimes they're coloring loudly or sometimes they got to get
up and go to the bathroom and all of those things happen.
But we as a church meaning you
and me.
Must be okay with that and supportive
of that because we want
those kids to love the church.
We want them to be able to know what it's like to be a part
of the church their whole lives. If they don't love the church. Now,
they've certainly won't love the church when they leave.
And so are they going to see from us?
Anger towards them distraction by them if we're
distracted by that then maybe that says something more
about us than about them because they're kids.
Right, they they're not going to sit listen for 35
minutes in a row and be completely on point because you're
not even that way, right?
I mean, I know I I've said listen to sermons too. I know you don't
catch everything.
I mean my mind wanders off for a few minutes like oh, yeah.
We're point two. Okay, here we are.
It's a training process.
We should be mature enough to handle those Wiggles.
Right and support that and love that encourage that
I'd say it. Here's a Here's a thought. I said in my email
today go find a new person on Sunday that you don't know that you
haven't seen before go meet them. Encourage them be a welcoming presence.
If you see a family bringing in their little ones.
Go Champion that.
Go say and I'm so thankful. You care
enough with your kids to bring them here and love the church. I love that.
Do you need any help? Can I help you? Like, you know, can I sit with
your kids too and maybe if you need a break, let me tell you
know, whatever but just encourage it. Let's celebrate
that. I think it's huge.
last thing
I'm not talking about this.
purely, but
One thing I know from my own experience and from
everything. I've done as a minister children need
to see a Godly joy-filled marriage
first and foremost.
Again, I know their situations. I know it's not ideal for
everyone.
But they need to see that.
So if you don't know my story my parents got divorced and I was a freshman in high
school.
So I understood everything it was happening.
But I remember.
Sort of been like January.
Two three something like that.
I remember my mom.
that night after
she asked him to leave because of the adultery.
ongoing
but I tried to work it out that night.
Or that afternoon. She told me that dad's leaving
Dad's Gone.
My sister had already gone to college and so it's
just me and her but I remember.
that night in my room just
weeping balling
because I knew everything was going to be different at that point.
And somehow I remember thinking this somehow
I thought it was my fault.
It wasn't in any way.
But the emotional need had not been met faulty thinking.
all of those things
right
all that collapsed in that moment.
It's my fault.
And I'm just ripped apart.
And so again, I know there's unique situations
and we'll walk with that. We'll walk as
best we can through that and fill the gaps that we can but marriage
matters in parenting.
The best thing you can do as parents is to
have a healthy flourishing marriage.
Where both of you are pursuing Jesus with
everything you are.
Where both of you are competing to see how high you
can get towards Jesus right? I mean just setting
the pace dads of course, but but both of
you setting the pace toward Jesus, so your kids know
they are safe.
We even tell our kids because we're we're around people.
They know my mom's story.
Limited
But they know that's not my dad so they have to ask the
question like where's who's your dad? Well, he's Grandpa Dawn
that comes from Denver every once in a while like you but they
have like
how does that how does that work? So they've had to figure it out early in
life friends get parents get divorced.
Every time that conversation comes up we look at them Square in the face and
we tell them directly out loud not. I'm not sugarcoat
in this.
I say boys.
You don't have to worry about us.
It's not an option for us.
Just because they need to hear that.
Right, they need to hear that truth again because they saw
their parent the friend's parents.
So their first thought might be a wonder if that's gonna happen
to us and I tell them immediately. No.
It's not an option for us.
We're gonna work through whatever it is. We're not doing anything stupid to get
us there. But we're also not going to allow it to break us that
we're going to work through everything.
You don't have to worry about that.
so
That's the best thing you can have for your
and again, if it's history that that's been a broken thing before
now, it's this way. Okay Own It repent walk
in Holiness now and say this is who
we're gonna be. Well, I failed five years ago. Now we're
gonna be this way because I know how much it
hurts you it hurts them. This is who we're
gonna be now, you can trust it and show them show them
show them every day the rest of your life. That's what
it is affection love unity. That's the
best thing they need.
It meets that need that they have they don't even know they have
they don't even know how to express it, but it meets it.
So let that be first.
if that's not possible, then let's
let's be examples of what it means to follow Jesus in the current situation. We're
in.
Right, everybody needs to see that because not every situation is
a perfect Ideal Husband wife a couple kids. Like
that's not just reality for everybody. So this family over here
this this they need to see somebody over here following Jesus like that.
So they can learn how to do that because they can't can't do it
like this anymore because whatever but but they can
see that and that's a great example for them of how to follow Jesus
in their situation. It's the body of Christ right coming together.
So let's be passionately following Jesus first and
foremost ourselves as couples as families, and
we'll see God work in us
and through us as we pray. Let's pray
now as we pray for our kids God. Thank you
so much for tonight.
Thank you for your blessings.
First of salvation of mercy and Grace that we don't deserve and we're
grateful for that. We pray now as
As parents grandparents Guardians influencers,
whatever Lord we pray that as we see this
responsibility even more intensely now.
You would bless our efforts towards that that you
would Empower our efforts towards that that we see good fruit come
from just a diligent effort towards.
Bringing our children up in the discipline instruction of the
Lord.
God keep us
from provoking them
When we do exasperate our children, God lead us
to repentance quickly.
before you first and then before our kids
to repent to our kids when we blow it God may
that be normal.
So that they learn how to repent too.
Show us Lord how to lead these gifts.
You've entrusted to us how to lead them towards you.
We know we cannot change their hearts. We can't be the Catalyst towards
salvation for them. We can be an Avenue you
use a tool you use to bring them to you, but we can't change
their hearts God.
That's why we need you to do it.
We pray that you would lead us to be.
Faithful followers of you with all that we are your priority
number one and that that would be who our kids are as well.
And they would change the world.
They would follow you. They would not fall into the traps and
hiccups and pitfalls that we've fallen
into in our lives, but they would learn and follow you
with all that they are their whole lives.
Help us. Holy spirit Empower us we can't
do this ourselves. So we lean on you we need
you.
We're desperately dependent on you to do what only you can do
God.
So Empower this tonight as we go that even tonight
with kids with grandkids with our spouses
with our friends even tonight. We'd be
different.
For Your Glory in Jesus name amen
Amen, thanks everybody.
You are sent.